j.t brubaker looking for that win we
talked about bob he has not had that w
since the end of may two bowls and one
strike on dylan carlson rips it into
right field for a base hit
cut off by polanco and a leadoff hit for
dylan
carlson running and
an easy stolen base brubacher just
throwing his hands up runner at second
dylan carlson there's nolan arnotto
oronato hits it down the left field line
fair end of the corner one nothing
cardinals
kicked around by alford so
nolan oronato at second base with a
double and it's one nothing st louis
here in the first and today it is wade
leblanc
seven starts since joining the rotation
back on the 28th of june
and a little fly ball to shallow center
field and a diving try but he can't come
up with it and hayes is going to try for
second vader gets to it quickly but gets
past
the young
will be a double for hayes
colin moran the two hits
off wainwright last night
ball hit a long way to right center
field it's a long way to tipperary
colin moran clears the deck with a
cannonball to give the pirates a 3-1
lead
his fifth of the year i think the ball's
going to carry in this hot weather
3-1 pitch
vader hit by the pitch and the leadoff
man is aboard
the pitch is swung on grounded to short
newman has it he'll flip it on the first
for the out and the inning is through
and a swing and a ball hit to where no
one was
out in the shallow right center field a
base hit for polanco
polanco running and the tag is there
caught stealing what a throw by kisner
so two outs pitch popped up
it'll be carpenter with the catch behind
the bag
popped up and stallings oh can hang on
as he looked toward the wall
shelton's going to argue something here
with fielding culberth and he's going to
gather the other umpires perhaps
carlson's backswing hit him
so something up there obviously with
leblanc yeah obviously they had to go
out there and talk to the umpires for
some injury
um related situation because he's
getting all the time he needs to get
loose
ground ball double play six four
three
and a lead off walk gotta make him pay
hank let's go
high fly ball out to left at the wall
gone
it stayed fair
and paul de young with a two run homer
to tie it up at three
he loves hitting bombs at pnc
oh one two new bar and he crushes one
out to deep right at the wall
gone
pinch it
two-run
bomb large
nude bar
i can hear it all over in st louis new
with his first career home run
now we gotta get the offense going again
moran's a good guy to get started
and that one hit a long way to right
center field approaching the wall and
clear the deck a second time
with a cannonball for colin moran don't
you know
he's homered in back-to-back advance
it's his sixth of the year
good work from chris tuno of the
cardinals pr staff wade leblanc removed
with left elbow pain
dylan carlson taken out of the game with
right wrist soreness
well that's maybe the most efficient
yeah inning for brubacher
ground ball good pitch 99 from garcia
and hayes retired
his underwood fires it into center bader
on his way to third it'll be an air on
dwayne underwood junior as tommy put it
in play
kisner chops it up the middle
and the only play is to go to first and
a run will score and it's back to a
two-run st louis lead
little chopper towards goldie so cabrera
will win that battle
and the ground out to first
2-1 lifted out to left rondon with the
catch
and a one two three for cabrera
here's the 2-1
rolled up the third base line no play
for hayes and a base hit now five for 10
against dwayne underwood so it's first
and second and paul de young who has
looked very good at the plate today
nice
night the knees good fastball
time to stretch and get some runs
go out of play
hank wants to see the strikeouts
with the catch
a basket catch
hopping over third base to make sure he
didn't trip on it
and that is good to see a line drive
headed toward the fence
vader does a nice job to cut it off but
it's a double for kevin newman
and that oh what a play by goldsmith but
he can't find the ball
so now the go-ahead run at the plate
tying runs are on at first and third
3-2 is popped up
called the young puts it away the
pirates have left three on we head to
the eighth and it's six for cardinals
the o2 pitch
right there strike three call well he
strikes out the side out of 10 pitches
pretty good pretty good
the other way
for hayes
starts the eighth yeah lead off man
aboard tying run
past the mound and just a roller that
will be a base hit for defoe
[Applause]
one two pitch swung on and missed three
strikeouts for gallegos 6-4 we ended the
night
lying down to left
and extra bases for jose rondon
alford it's snuck under his glove
and rondon winds up at looking for
insurance
goldschmidt hits it down the right field
line fair
one hopper off the wall rondon will
score goldie to second base
not sure he realized he hit it fair but
he did and the cardinals
pick up a run here in the ninth and it's
now a 7-4 lead
and the fly ball to right field and
clear the deck with a cannonball and
anchor down
ryan reynolds
makes it a one-run game
the towering homer
and that'll bring the tiger under the
plate one strike away from his sweep the
1-2
he got him it's a sweep in pittsburgh
for st louis called third strike and the
cardinals hold on seven to six